>> Alright, so I just introduced this Q function. It
turns out that baked into this one little Q function is
everything we need for, for dealing with U and pi without
knowing the transition function T or the reward function R. And
to you know, to demonstrate this for you, I'm going to
let you demonstrate it to me. [LAUGH] So, [LAUGH] here's what
I'd like you to do. I'd like you to rewrite these
equations, this U and the pi equation, in the little boxes,
using Q instead of any references to T and
R, alright? So, imagine that we have Q, that somebody's
already solved this out for us. How can we
define pi and U using Q? Does that seem okay?
>> Seems okay to me. I think I might even know the answer.
>> Alright, that would be awesome. So let's, let's give people a
chance to think about it and then just tell me what you think.
>> Okay.